Yeah.
Somebody asked,
what's up with all the lending teachers
in your house and then how is it to look
at them every day?
Well,
about
in 2001 you to see it of
manic collective insanity.
I decided to start seeing if I could
find Soviet era artists ox online,
mostly through Ebay.
I had read a paper by James
Pennebaker who claimed that uh,
past events start to become historically
significant about 15 years after the,
after the relevant event.
And so 2001 was 15 years after the fall,
essentially after the fall of
the Berlin Wall or close enough.
And so I started looking on Ebay to see
what sort of Soviet artifacts or might
be able to find.
Um,
first of all,
I was kind of curious about what
would be available for purchase.
And I also saw it as deeply ironic
that the most free market of,
of what would you call
platforms ever device,
which would be Ebay could now be used
to scavenge communist era artists,
Alex from Russia.
You know,
it just seemed like to be someone
who was raised during the Cold War.
The fact that that,
that I could buy things like heads of
Lennon on Ebay was just too comical to not
to pass up,
you know.
And so I started buying things that I
had some familiarity with because of what
I'd read historic.
Again,
the first thing I bought was about a three
by five silk flag that was awarded to
a factory for meeting its
five year production quota.
And I don't know what you know
about those infamous quotas,
but what would happen is that
there were dicta sent down on high,
but how much factories were
supposed to produce and the implied,
um,
what the implication was produced
or else by any means necessary.
And so two things happened,
three things happened.
The goods were often shoddy
because they were rushed.
There was deception about how much was
actually produced and then people were
radically over worked and under supplied.
So it was a bad about and system.
But it was very interesting to actually
have one of these flags and see what
they were like.
And then I bought a block,
a stainless steel plot,
windup clock that was a submarine clock.
And it was bomb proof.
So I thought that would be
handy if someone ever bombed
my house and I needed to
know what time it was.
So I bought that.
And then I found this painting
that's actually off to my left here.
It's five Russian revolutionaries,
all younger and court stalwart looking,
standing on the edge of a cliff with a
red soldier or a white soldier off to
decide they're all shackled together
and he's preparing to execute them.
And that was,
uh,
that was,
a fairly common Soviet motif.
And,
um,
on my right side,
I have a,
a decorated Soviet war hero who's,
who's working in a steel foundry and
like a lot of the Soviet art glorified,
I suppose the,
the working class.
And I suppose there's nothing wrong
with that depending on the degree of
propagandistic intent and falsifications.
But,
um,
they're kind of like
Norman Rockwell paintings,
except they don't have the
same degree of sentimentality,
which is quite interesting.
And what's it like to have them around?
Well,
pretty much every square inch of
my house is covered with paintings.
And a fair number of them are,
I don't suppose the sorts of paintings
that people would usually have in their
house.
There are,
some of them are of the Second World War.
Some of them are strongly
political and uh,
but it's,
it's,
well sometimes people say,
well I wouldn't want to live in a museum.
And I guess that isn't how I feel.
I actually like living in a museum and
I like having these historical artifacts
around and I really like watching the
propaganda and the art more in the,
in the paintings because many of these
paintings were produced by very talented
impressionist artists who are trained
in the classical European tradition.
They spent months making these paintings
and yet their subordinate in some sense
to a political ideology.
But what's interesting is that as the
political ideology recedes into the past,
the more purely artistic elements
of the painting seem to remain.
And so it's cool to kind of watch,
it's very slow process,
but it's very interesting to watch.
The art itself emerged
triumphant over the propaganda.
And then,
you know,
these things also remind me of what,
what I'm interested in.
And that's the study of videology.
And they reminded me how powerful
ideology can be and how many different
pathways it can take,
two to,
to control,
I suppose.
And,
and,
and it also reminds me of the reality
of the 20th century because it was a
terrible reality.
And if we forget it,
then we were likely to repeat it.
Now,
my kids grew up in this
house and you know,
they,
I asked them about it because as far as
the paintings are fairly heavy and maybe
even somewhat frightening,
but they really liked it
and people that I had,
it gives me a reason to invite people
into my house and gives me something to
play with.
And,
and I,
I guess I need things to
play with by all appearances.
So that's the story of the,
of the Soviet paintings.
So.